foreign
[Music]
most of us just love a good film
Malaysian but it's pretty hard to
understand how to create effect in such
a way that it's rendering a natural and
subtle relation bleeding so in today's
video I'll show you exactly how I
correct the best relation settings and
how to understand what each slider is
actually doing before we start it took
me quite some time experimenting and
testing hundreds of shots to find these
settings so why not hit the like button
and share this video with other people
that might need this in their workflow
okay no more time wasting let's get into
DaVinci
enter the color tab either pressing on
it or hitting hotkey shift 4 on Windows
or command 4 on Mac in the upright
Corner hit the effects menu and search
for halation
drag it on top of the desired node and
let's start analyzing the first options
we'll be working with
first thing we have color space
processing Either Leave it to your
project timeline input or you can open
and choose a type of color space you
have shot it in this particular video
was shot on a cinechrome Sony film
simulation recipe which uses a BT 2020
color space so I'll just go ahead and
choose BT 2020. these Sony film
simulations are based off the picture
profile menu so if you're interested in
film simulations for Sony cameras go
check out my website for the picture
profile settings
back to the solutions menu you can leave
the isolation and the dye layer as they
are for the moment and let's jump
directly to the secondary glow I'll
guide you through a couple adjustments
and afterwards I will explain what and
why
so bring up the strength and lift the
gamma all the way to the top as you can
see the halation is pretty gross right
now is already showing very strongly
throughout the image so bring down the
spread
looks better but the colors are still
very vibrant the main problem here is
the secondary glow color is bright red
so let's change the color of the filter
to a dark brown tone and that will solve
most of our problems
so as a basic explanation Collision
takes place in areas of high contrast
usually between sky and Dark Shadow so
what I've done here actually is I
boosted the power and the contrast of
the secondary glow to make sure the
hellish will show up even in areas of
lower contrast like between branches for
example and reduce the spread to a
minimum so it's not bleeding all over
the place making it present over the
whole image but in a very subtle way
also I've changed the initial color
regulation effect which was very bright
and vibrant the darker shade of orange
and that is meant to solve the color
brightness problem while also giving
natural tone down inflation effect
looking great already some people like
this kind of a look and they can stop
right here but for a more natural and
organic look let's continue with a
couple Minor Adjustments if the dilated
reflection bring down the strength such
as by pinch and you can bring up the
gamma to increase the lation in areas of
lower contrast
but that's your choice
you can also adjust the spread level
even more to reduce or increase the
bleeding of the resolution effect
and there is also relative spread which
can be shown by checking this box here
you can balance out individual color
channels like red green and blue
flavoring one over the other will make
it more dominant but we'll leave this
for another video
next and final steps in the isolation
submenu set the Threshold at your
desired level each clip will require a
different threshold level since each
clip will have a different highlight
point so adjusted your own liking and
depending how much of the image you want
affected by the resolution lastly film
saturation this is again your personal
choice but I would recommend going for
something very subtle from 0.10 to 0.35
I've included these settings in my cine
rack 60 millimeter film print together
with more refined color adjustments that
will give you authentic film look which
can be used on any kind of footage Rex
1109 or log 10 bit and even 8-bit I've
tested it on the new area Alexa 35
cinema camera and it looks great you can
go check out that video I put a link in
the upright Corner if you like these
settings give this video a like and
share it with people all my film packs
come with multiple color palettes
variations to give you more options to
choose from and you can find the power
grid on my website go check it out Link
in description down below you can also
download the basic Note 3 which has my
location settings in it or other free
Luts on my website
so this is it for the video till next
time have fun and take care see ya